Let's get started on a business collaboration agreement.
Would you mind taking a shot at the first draft?
No problem.
I'll have the legal department work on it.
We have a standard template for a business alliance,...
...so I think I can send the first draft by the end of next week.
Sounds good.
As soon as I receive it, I'll have my team review it.
Good. Thank you, Taka.
Well, I think it's about time to wrap it up.
Victoria, do you have anything to add?
No, I think we've covered everything.
Ok then, our action items today are to set up a conference call with the engineering teams next week.
And I will send you an initial draft of the partnership agreement by the end of next week.
Sounds right to me.
Thank you all for a very productive meeting today.
I hope it's the first of many more to come!